(classical music)
- [Male] We are the paradoxical ape.
Bipedal, naked, large brain,
lone the master of
tools, fire and language
but still trying to understand ourselves.
Aware that death is inevitable
yet filled with optimism.
We grow up slowly.
We hand down knowledge.
We empathize and deceive.
We shape the future
from our shared understanding of the past.
Carta brings together experts
from diverse disciplines
to exchange insights on who we are
and how we got here.
An exploration made possible
by the generosity of humans like you.
(upbeat music)
- Thank you for the invitation.
It's been really exciting for me.
This talk is gonna be about brains
and I'm not gonna actually talk
about primates or humans
but I'm gonna come to some
conclusions about humans
and culture.
So this is the brain of
a bottlenose dolphin,
the back of the brain
of a bottlenose dolphin
and this is the brain of a small marsupial
and you can see the
neocortex is really large
and I'm gonna talk about
the neocortex today,
very specifically for a couple of reasons.
One is that it's the part of the brain
that's changed most dramatically
in mammals over time
and in humans in particular,
they have an extremely large neocortex.
It's the part of the brain
that's involved in cognition, language,
and things like tool use.
The question
that we're interested in
addressing in my laboratory
is how the brain gets more complex
or how the neocortex gets more complex.
So we know that early mammals
had a neocortex that was very, very tiny
and had a few cortical fields.
And cortical fields are
the functional units
of the neocortex.
And we know that as brains evolved,
and particularly primate brains
the neocortex became
a really, really enormous cortical sheet
that now is proposed,
humans are proposed to have
hundreds of cortical fields.
So the question is how do you get
from a very, very simple form
to a very, very complicated form.
But this is a serious problem to address
because these types of changes,
certainly from early mammals,
are 200 million years of changes.
And we can even see the sorts of changes
that have occurred in the human line
over a six million year period.
So how do you address these changes?
And there are two ways that you can get
at this question of evolution.
You can say what has evolution produced?
And the way we can understand
what evolution has produced
is we look at brains and bodies,
we do a comparative approach.
So I can look at a lot of different brains
using a variety of different techniques,
electrophysiological, anatomical,
and I can say, what sorts
of changes have come about?
The problem is evolution
is a moving picture
and the life of an individual
is a moving picture.
So any time we study an
individual or a mammal,
we're taking one snapshot of
that moving picture of life
and trying to figure it out.
So what we do with a comparative analysis
is we look at a lot of snapshots
and try to put this moving
picture back together.
However, while these sort
of comparative studies
can tell us what evolution has produced,
they don't tell us how
phenotypic transformations occur,
how do I get more cortical fields?
How do I change connections of a cortex
which in turn changes behavior?
And this is where studies of development
come into play
because the evolution of any aspect
of the body, the brain,
is actually the evolution
of developmental mechanisms
that give rise to that
aspect of the phenotype.
So my talk is gonna focus a little bit
on this.
So comparative analysis,
this is many, many years of work.
This is a cladogram
and these are neocortices.
And you're gonna see
these sort of cartoons
throughout the talk.
This is the neocortex.
These red and blue and yellow areas
indicate cortical fields.
And the most important
thing to take away from this
is that you can have common ancestors,
which we don't know about,
humans, macaque monkeys, cats, squirrels.
There is a constellation
of cortical fields
that all species possess,
even in the absence of use,
and this is due to inheritance
from a common ancestry
and it's also due to the
way genes are deployed
in development.
But that's gonna be a different story.
So there are similarities in brains.
My brain is very similar to
a mouse brain in some ways
but it's also very different.
And here are some of
the sorts of differences
you're gonna see.
This is a flattened view of the neocortex.
This is the front of the brain,
this is the top of the brain.
This is a macaque monkey
and this is a mouse.
And they're not drawn to scale.
This would actually,
this mouse neocortex would
be a little tiny portion
of the macaque neocortex.
And what we can see
is that there are changes in
the size of the cortical sheet,
there are changes in
cortical field number,
there are changes in the
relative size of cortical fields.
There are changes in
the connection patterns
of homologous cortical fields.
And of course the question is
to what extent are these
differences due to genes
that are intrinsic to
the developing neocortex?
Have they changed in species over time?
And they probably have.
Genes associated with the
development of the body.
Because the body changes,
we use the body differently
and you cannot think about the brain
without thinking about the body.
There's a middle man there, right?
The brain is not embodied itself.
It needs the body
to provide all information
about the world.
Epigenetic influences.
And by this I mean sensory-driven
or environmental or context-driven changes
to the brain and the body.
Or is it some combination
of these factors?
Is any creature due to
just one sort of thing
or is it some sort of
combination in different species
over the course of evolution?
So I'm gonna give you some examples
of comparative work
and changes in peripheral morphology
that give us some clue
about what the answer to that question is.
So this is one of my very
favorite examples on the planet.
It's a duck-billed platypus.
This is a real animal, this is the bill
and what's really cool, yeah
and the reason I'm also
interested in the body
is when I started working on
different animals in Australia,
I had to catch every
single animal I worked on
and it gives you a really,
really great appreciation
for the body and how important it is
because they're hard to catch.
Anyway, I digress.
So what's really cool about the platypus
is that it has mechanosensory receptors
that are exquisitely sensitive to touch,
inter-digits with electrosensory
receptors on its bill,
and when it does anything important,
capture prey items, mate,
it closes its eyes, its ears and its nose.
So all it has is a bill.
And if you look at its neocortex
using electrophysiological
recording techniques,
this is the front of the brain,
this is the top of the brain,
this is the representation of the bill
on the cortical sheet.
There are a number of cortical fields.
So within the somatosensory cortex,
it takes up about 90% of the entire
representation of the
somatosensory cortex.
And if you look at the cortex itself,
it takes up about 75% of
the entire cortical sheet.
This animal is one big huge bill.
And it's hard to imagine,
this is called cortical magnification.
And the question is is this due to genes
intrinsic to the neocortex
that have made this
cortex one big huge bill,
changes to the body?
It has to be to some extent
due to changes in the body.
The environment and how the animal uses
the body in the environment.
And I gave you the example
of the duck-billed platypus
because it's an extraordinary example
of cortical magnification.
But we must appreciate that we see this
across the board in a lot of species,
including humans.
If you look at the evolution
of the supralaryngeal rack
and the specializations
of this body morphology,
we have an expanded representation,
somatosensory cortex, motor
cortex, premotor cortex
of this specialized structure
which we call Broca's Area.
So they are following the same roles
of evolution as other species.
I'm gonna switch really rapidly
to experimental manipulations
of peripheral morphology.
So you say, okay,
to what extent is the ratio
of incoming sensory inputs
to the developing neocortex
determining the functional
organization of the neocortex?
And for this,
we used little short-tailed opossums.
They are models of early blindness.
We bilaterally nucleated,
removed the eyes when
these animals are embryos.
So it's basically a little layer of skin.
We let them grow up
and we look at their connections,
we look at the functional
organization of their brain
and what we see is that
here's visual cortex
in this animal.
This is the front of the brain
and this is the top of the brain.
And all of what would
normally be visual cortex,
which is in blue here,
is now processing inputs
from the somatosensory
and auditory system.
So we've totally functionally
changed the reorganization
of this neocortex.
And if we look at the connections,
these are connections,
these are visual areas here in blue,
primary visual cortex
and it's getting input from
other visual structures.
These are auditory structures in yellow
and somatosensory structures in red.
And what we see in our bilateral nucleus
is that now the connections
of the brain have changed.
We've done nothing to
the neocortex itself,
not one thing.
We've simply removed all visual input
really early in development.
And what we see is this
functional takeover
and connectional takeover
of the developing brain.
And if we look at what that
region is representing,
which would normally be visual,
it's representing the head vibracy.
We've basically,
I want to say we've
made a platypus, right?
So something like 80% of the neocortex
is now processing inputs from this stuff,
from the vibracy and
the snout and the face.
And of course, it's
great to have a big brain
and transform the neocortex
but you have to ask yourself
what does this mean for behavior?
Which is the target of selection.
And so we had train discrimination tasks
and natural behavior.
And I wanted to show
you the natural behavior
'cause it's really cool.
These animals,
they end up becoming
super tactile animals.
They do really, really well
with tactile discrimination tasks.
This is the ladder rung task
where the animal starts at one end
of this ladder and moves to the other end
and you train him to walk
on evenly spaced rungs.
And then what you do is you
then space the rungs unevenly
and you have him do this task again.
And I'm gonna show you
some movies of this.
This is a normal animal,
this is a bilateral nucleate
and this is really pretty beautiful.
So here's what a normal animal looks like
and you can score them based
on when their legs fall through
and how well they do.
You'll see this
and his legs falling
through, oops, oops, oops.
He was trained but this
is now a novel task.
Here's the bilateral nucleate,
no eyes whatsoever.
So it's never had any
access to visual input ever.
And so this is what the
bilateral nucleate looks like
on this novel task.
Look at this, bam.
Okay, this is good.
Okay, so we propose
that because the whiskers are so important
and have this huge representation
of the whiskers now,
we trim the whiskers.
I know, I know, I know.
They grew back, they grew back, okay.
But check this out.
This is so cool.
This is the same animal
with his whiskers trimmed.
And here's what happens.
So this is really cool
because you are showing
this enormous brain change
and behavior change
and the two coincide.
And just to end this
little tiny portion of it.
So blindness is not an absence of light
because this animal has
functional respecification
changes in cortical and
subcortical connections,
a really big magnification of its vibracy.
So its entire nervous system
has been kind of rewired and reorganized
based on this lack of sensory input.
But that's pretty,
that's sort of like taking a
sledgehammer to the system.
Let me show you something
a little more subtle.
This is natural differences
in rearing conditions,
cultural transmission of rearing style
and these are voles.
Voles are biparental,
both parents rear their young.
And we can measure differences
in total tactile contact with the young.
We look at high contact
parents and low contact parents
and important to remember,
is that high contact offspring
show differences in behavior,
high contact offspring
become high contact parents
and if you cross foster
them on the day of birth,
you take low contact parents
and put them with high contact parents,
they become high contact parents.
So this is a social
transmission of a rearing style.
And if we look at the connections
of their somatosensory cortex,
particularly in the regions
of the body that are being touched,
we see the connections
are mostly the same.
This is an injection site
and these are connections to it.
But we also see
differences in connections.
And remember this is pretty subtle.
And differences in connections
of frontal cortex as well.
So what factors contribute
to the phenotype?
So I'm just showing you a
much more subtle example
of the role of sensory input
in shaping the brain,
in shaping connectivity.
Well genes definitely contribute
to cortical sheet size,
cortical field size,
cortical connections,
peripheral morphology
and cellular mechanisms
involved in plasticity,
maybe genetically specified
which allows the environment to impact
some of these same things.
I can change cortical field
size, cortical connectivity,
peripheral morphology,
which I showed in these experiments.
And I've given you examples
from the bill of the platypus
and I suggested the same
thing is occurring in humans
but what about things
like social learning,
language and culture?
I would suggest
that the best way to think about these
as these are simply complex
patterns of physical stimuli
that are impinging on the
developing nervous system.
So mothers love is temperature, touch,
cadence of a voice, nothing more.
And this can impact how
the brain wires itself.
It can impact size of cortical fields
and connections of cortical fields.
So I'm gonna end a little bit with this.
This is a human evolution,
not quite a cladogram.
And on the bottom is
environment and social context
and on the top it's
sort of truncated here,
is meant to be morphology or genes.
And modern hand is proposed
to have been around this
for about 700,000 years
but what's really pretty fascinating
is that until recently,
we were using stone tools.
And big brains happened way back here.
So we had the big brain,
we had the modern hand
but we were not doing what we're doing
with the modern hand.
And if you believe that all behaviors
is generated by the brain,
and I believe that all behavior
then the brain must've changed.
And if the brain didn't change
by changes in DNA sequence,
it must've changed by
activity-dependent mechanisms
and/or culture.
And so, it's hard to believe
that the industrial revolution
was less than 300 years ago.
And if you look,
we've actually changed
the scape of this planet
and now we have daily and
prolonged interactions
with computers and machines and tools,
really sophisticated tools.
And I'll end by saying
we are combinatorial creatures
constructed by genes, bodies, behaviors
and environmental context
and I think, you can look for the genes
that are distinguishing humans,
I think you're gonna find only a few,
maybe some involved
in expansion of the neocortex.
But humans that have evolved
an extraordinary capacity
to construct our neocortex
over the course of a prolonged infancy
and childhood allowing for
rapid phenotypic change
even within a single generation.
I would say that if Leah
Krubitzer were born 30 years ago
or 100 years ago or 300,000 years ago,
I wouldn't be Leah Krubitzer
hitting a rock or using a spear,
I would be a different brain.
We have a remarkable
fluid brain body interface
with the environment
such that tools and machines
can extend our embodiment
and our peri personal space
and expand the loop between our brains,
our bodies and the world.
And I think this has made us
unique biohybrid creatures
who's brains adapt and
bootstrap themselves
with the technologies that we give rise to
and for better or worse,
with whom are futures are
increasingly entwined.
Okay, thank you.
(audience applause)
- Paleoanthropologists once thought
humans evolved in Europe and Asia
around 40 to 50,000 years ago.
We now know homo sapiens evolved in Africa
more than 100 to 300,000 years ago.
The evidence showing these earlier humans
behaved in similar ways to recent humans
continues to surprise us.
But should it?
Here's an example.
Several weeks ago,
there was an article published in Nature,
an abstract drawing from
the 73,000 year old levels
at Blombos Cave in South Africa.
Now this is an important discovery
and it's published in one
of the world's foremost
and prestigious scientific journals
but abstract drawings are
human cultural universals.
You're looking at some of them right now.
Everyone makes them.
Shouldn't we expect
that humans who lived in
South Africa 73,000 years ago
made abstract drawings too?
Are early humans not
behavioring modern humans?
Were they these primitive humans
that anthropologists have been
looking for and not finding
for more than two centuries?
I think we have to ask
what is behavioral modernity
and take a closer look at it.
It's inferred quality
based on unexpected
archeological discoveries,
art, symbols, carved bone
tools and similar things
rather than things predicted
from prior evolutionary theory
before the excavations started.
Modernity claims come first,
supporting evidence, arguments
and theoretical justifications
are developed after the fact.
This is not a good way to do science
and it is a demonstrably
poor way to do justice
because long ago, people
in Salem, Massachusetts
used this same approach
to identify witches.
Witchcraft accusations came first.
Evidence was then gathered
and theories developed after the fact.
More than 200 people were accused,
dozens jailed.
19 hanged and one tortured to death.
And yet Massachusetts exonerated
most accused and convicted
witches 17 years later in 1703.
Why should we expect our search
for prehistoric behaviorally modern humans
to be any more successful and enduring
than Salem's search for witches?
I don't think we should.
So what's wrong with behavioral modernity?
First off, it's anti-evolutionary.
It assumes all humans evolved convergently
towards the same end
and regardless of divergent
selective pressures.
Secondly, it's a metaphor
rather than measurable
property of the evidence.
And a metaphor that
archeologists choose selectively.
It doesn't predict.
All of its interpretations
are made after the fact.
I think it's better to focus,
and I'll propose,
it's better to focus on
behavioral complexity instead.
With behavioral modernity,
different lightning bolts
will all produce the same
kinds of stone tools.
Don't nap outdoors
during a lightning storm.
With behavioral complexity,
different causes beget different results.
So what is behavioral complexity?
Well, key features of complex phenomena
include multiple parts
that interact with one
another systematically.
Different inputs create different outputs.
And historical and geographic
variation among inputs
creates complexly-patterned variability
among the outputs.
That whole system,
too much systems theory.
Here's a practical example.
Folk art is a complex phenomenon
in which artists, cultures,
materials and markets
interact dynamically with one another.
If you think folk art is simple
do please join us in Santa Fe, New Mexico
for the International Folk Art Festival
that happens each July.
Handcrafted artifacts vary
historically and geographically
in complexly patterned ways.
So how complex was early
human stone working?
Today, stone working or making stone tools
is a handy craft, a folk art,
of which I'm a practitioner.
It's also a reasonable
source of hypotheses
about prehistoric stoneworking
because it's familiar, we can observe it.
If early Homo sapiens
had similar capacities
for behavioral variability,
excuse me, for behavioral
complexity to ours
and different ones from earlier hominins,
then their first appearances
in the fossil record
should coincide with onsets
of complexly patterned
stone tool variability.
Here's a prediction.
Does it?
Well indeed it does.
After 100 to 300,000 years ago,
Homo sapiens first appearances everywhere
coincide with increasingly
complex and patterned
stone tool variability.
So what is complexly patterned
stone tool variability?
I hope this slide captures it well.
To make my point,
I've stripped away all
the hints you would have
to the origins of these artifacts
from their raw materials
and substituted them with drawings.
The objects in blue here
date to more than 300,000 years ago
and their artifact designs,
their shapes, their morphology,
their patterns of modification,
only weakly indicate geographic origin
and their age, if they do so at all.
Now in the past, I've
offered to have a contest
and offered a $20 bill
to anybody who can guess
where the object,
the teardrop shaped object comes from,
but I'm told that that
would be improper, hehe.
(giggles)
Okay, now less than 100,000 years ago,
artifact designs indicate
age and geographic origin
with increasing precision.
The objects outlined
in red are a bit older,
they're closer to around
100,000 years ago.
If you're to guess their ages,
you'd probably come within 10,000 years,
maybe 100,000 years.
But the objects in black,
the objects in black are more recent.
They're younger than 40,000 years.
And with some of them,
we can narrow down their
occurrence to 2,000 years.
The object, let's see,
one, two, three, four,
fourth from the right there,
the one with the hollow sort of base,
that's an artifact found
here in North America
but from the Mississippi
River to the Rocky Mountains
and up to the Great Plains
over the course of about two centuries.
Excuse me, 2,000 years.
What do stone tools teach us?
First off, stone tools are
indestructible evidence
about mind-technology relationships.
This evidence shows complex
mind-technology relationships
were in place among early humans
at least 100 to 300,000 years ago.
Increasingly complex stone tool
and other artifact variability
since 100,000 years ago
suggests mind-technology
relationships changed
during the course of human evolution.
So if we're trying to discover
the influence of the mind on technology
and technology on the mind,
we need to remember we're
shooting at a moving target.
So why?
These are the fun questions.
Why does stone tool variability
become increasingly complex and patterned?
Tools can be evolutionarily advantageous
but they come with costs
few other animals tolerate.
Other primates occasionally use tools
but only Homo sapiens are
obligatory tool users.
Obligatory tool use is irreversible,
even the best survival
experts require tools.
How many of you guys will
fess up to seeing this show,
Naked and Afraid?
Come on, you've seen this.
I know at least one other
of you in the audience
has been like me, recruited
to participate in it.
I don't want to treat my students
to pictures of me running
around without clothes.
They couldn't get
insurance for this program
unless they equipped the
contestants with tools.
It wouldn't be called Naked and Afraid,
it would be called Naked and Dead.
Now as I say, it's irreversible,
we can't go back.
More tool use increases
cultural differences potential,
influence on tool making strategies.
I like to call this the no,
you're doing it wrong effect.
So what do we know,
what do we not know
and what do we want to know?
We know obligatory tool use
is intrinsically complex and variable
and these are quantities we can measure
using the stone tool evidence.
We do not know
whether obligatory tool use
was a uniquely derived characteristic
of Homo sapien's behavior
or one shared by other
hominins now extinct,
such as denisovans and
neanderthals, perhaps.
We find ourselves in a happy spot
where we have new research questions.
You always want to come up
with new research questions.
You don't want to just hang up your spears
and go do something else.
How did obligatory tool
use change the human mind
from earlier primate
and hominin conditions?
And how do we didect obligatory tool use?
Now some of my colleagues might say,
and I'm not referring
to anyone in the room,
some of my colleagues might say
we have an arsenal of ways
of measuring stone tools
and quantifying their variability
that we've been using for 200 years.
But archeologists
who formulated those
measurements 200 years ago
weren't thinking about
obligatory tool use.
So we're in a situation
where we have a tool box
full of hammers and chisels
and we're setting forth
to change the battery
on an iPhone.
So I don't think the existing tools
archeologists used to
characterize the stone tool record
are necessarily unhelpful
but we have to prove that value.
Thank you.
(audience applause)
- I'd like to thank Tim and Pat
for inviting me to this
very interesting symposium
and of course the entire
Carta organization.
Language coevolved with the human brain
throughout evolution of Homo sapiens.
Writing, on the other hand,
which is actually what my topic is,
is a relatively new technology
that was invented by humans
to translate spoken
language into a visual form
for the purpose of transmitting
verbal communication
broadly to many people over
large distances and time.
As such, reading and writing
can be considered the first social media.
Reading is an example of what's
called neuronal recycling,
the recruitment of previously
evolved neural circuits
to accomplish cultural innovations.
It's important to point out
that while language develops
naturally in most humans
based on exposure rather
than explicit instruction,
reading and writing require
painstaking instruction
and years of practice
to reach proficiency.
This slide shows the typical
reading brain network
with its key components
as established initially in an older view
by studies of patients with
acquired brain lesions.
And more recently, using modern
brain imaging technologies,
we have a lot more information.
This talk will trace the history
of the invention of writing,
how English writing developed
and ended up with such a
cockeyed spelling system
which leads in many cases to dyslexia,
and discuss how modern technologies
are impacting reading and writing today.
I'd like to begin with a brief overview
of the history of the
invention of writing.
Writing is a physical manifestation
of a spoken language.
It's thought that human beings
developed spoken language
about 35,000 BC
as evidenced by, wow
yeah, by cave paintings
from the period of cro magnum man.
Writing numbers for the
purpose of record keeping
began long before writing of language.
Written language doesn't emerge
until the invention in Sumer
in southern Mesopotamia
around 3,500 BC.
This writing system is
known as Cuneiform writing.
It's generally agreed that
true writing of language
was independently conceived and developed
by at least two ancient
civilizations and possibly more.
In Sumer and also in
Mesoamerica by the Maya
in 500 to 300 BC.
Writing systems also arose
in Egypt around 3100 BC
and China around 1200 BC.
But historians debate
whether these writing systems
were developed completely
independently of Sumerian writing
or whether either or both were
inspired by Sumerian writing
by a process of cultural diffusion.
The Sumerian Cuneiform writing system
was in use for more than three millennia
through several stages of development
as can be seen on this slide
by looking at the
transformation of the sign
for head SAG
beginning with pictograms in 3000 BC.
Ultimately it was completely replaced
by alphabetic writing
in the general sense.
In the course of the Roman era,
there are no Cuneiform
writing systems in use today.
While the development
of Phoenician alphabet
is often attributed to,
the Phonetic alphabet is
also often contributed
to the Phoenicians,
they didn't actually
invent it or create it.
Rather, they imported it
piecemeal from Egypt and Crete
and took it to every city
on the Mediterranean.
By the time of Homer,
the Greeks were taking over the Phoenician
or allied Aramaic, alphabetic writing
and were calling it by the Semitic names
of the first two letters, alpha and beta.
The Latin alphabet was established
by the seventh century BC.
Before the invention of the
printing press in Europe
around 1455,
all books were handwritten
and usually highly decorated
until about the 12th century,
the most elaborate and
beautiful illuminations
were devoted to religious works
and most manuscripts were
produced in monasteries.
During the middle ages,
the Latin alphabet was used extensively
for writing in Europe.
With the age of colonialism
and Christian evangelism
the Latin scripts spread
widely well beyond Europe.
I'd now like to change the focus
to the history of English writing
and explain how English writing
ended up with such a
cockeyed spelling system
which leads in many cases to dyslexia.
The English language itself
is a compilation of several
different languages,
mostly Anglo-Saxon, French and Latin
because England just kept getting invaded
by people who spoke different languages.
The only thing we have in English
up until about 1400 are called patois.
They're a clumsy peasant language
without any standardized writing system.
There wasn't even a vocabulary
to carry on business in English.
It was all done in French or Latin.
However, when King Henry the Fifth
took the throne of England in 1412,
he had plans to invade France.
So speaking French wasn't gonna work.
He realized that if he
wanted to get support
from the common people,
they would have to change the language
of Parliament and business
from French to English.
At this time,
the only people who could
write at all in England
were just a handful of men
called chancery scribes
who wrote by hand and
almost exclusively in Latin.
Latin has a transparent
one to one correspondence
between the number of discrete
sounds, called phonemes,
in spoken Latin
and how they're mapped by
the letters in the alphabet.
As such, learning to read
Latin's a piece of cake.
All you have to do is
learn the single letter
that goes with each phoneme in Latin
and then just pronounce them in order
to produce words.
King Henry the Fifth
directed his chancery scribes
to create a written version of English
so that he could communicate
more broadly with his subjects.
However, there was
little or no instruction
as to how they were supposed to do this.
The problem they faced was
that the written Latin alphabet
was designed to represent one on one,
each of the 23 phonemes in spoken Latin.
It was never fit well for English
which has 44 phonemes.
For example, Latin didn't
have a sh, th or ch sound.
So with only 23 Latin letters,
there was no letter to represent these
and many of the other 44 English phonemes.
Faced with this problem,
the chancery scribes just apparently
made up multi-letter combinations
to represent these single phonemes.
So for example on this slide,
you could see that the letter string t-h-e
pronounced phonetically should be te-hu-e
and s-h-e, sa-hu-e.
So as many children are told
just say those and blend
the together quickly
and what do you get?
Sa-hu-e.
(audience laughing)
In case you ever wondered
how we ended up with the
non-transparent mapping
from spoken to written English
that leads so many children and people
learning English as a second language
to struggle to learn to read and spell.
It all began here in the 15th century.
Nearly 600 years before Gutenberg,
Chinese monks were setting ink to paper
using a method known as block printing.
What really set Gutenberg's
technology apart
from the Chinese
was the development of a press
that could mechanize the transfer of ink
from movable type to paper.
For the first time in history,
books could be mass produced.
Gutenberg's first major work in 1454
was the 42 line Gutenberg
bible printed in Latin.
With the invention of the printing press,
printing soon became the first
means of mass communication,
really the first social media.
It put more knowledge in the
hands of more people faster
and more cheaply than ever before.
As a result, reading and writing,
which up until that time
was really something
done by a very, very
small number of people
spread widely and rapidly.
Caxton brought the first printing press
from Bruges to London in 1476
for the Canterbury Tales.
With the advent of the printing press,
the complex and often cockeyed
spelling patterns for English
that remain to this day were solidified
giving rise to generation after generation
of children and adults
who struggled to learn to read and write,
particularly in English.
Let me acknowledge here that I'm indebted
to a wonderful website which
I'll highly recommend to you
called childrenofthecode.org.
The website's creator, David Bolton,
gave much of the information
by interviewing scientists
and anthropologists
for many years
and I've synthesized a
lot of this for this talk.
I highly recommend that
you explore this website
for additional information on this topic
of reading and writing,
the history of reading and writing
and especially dyslexia.
I quote from David Bolton,
"There weren't any cognitive scientists
"or neuroscientists or psychologists
"or even child development experts
"involved in creating the
English writing system.
"There wasn't any concern
"for hundreds of millions of children
"who would struggle
"since this code was
created in the 15th century.
"There were just a small
number of chancery scribes
"doing their very best
"to shove a technology created for Latin
"into a language it
was never designed for.
"Those who eventually do manage
to overcome the confusion
"and learn how to break the code,
"to become phonologically aware
"are able to use the areas of the brain
"that reading has recycled
from speech and language."
These areas here.
"Those who cannot break
this code become dyslexic."
According to the United
States Department of Education
in 2017, more than 60% of US
K through 12 school children
are reading below proficiency
and more than 70% writing
below the level of proficiency
for that grade level.
Let these stunning numbers sink in.
Reading is the skill that
matters most to success in school
and children who fall behind in reading
are in great academic danger.
But it's not just the
lack of reading skills
that most endanger these children.
It's the collateral damage.
It's their mind shame
that fates their future.
As seen on this video clip being shown
with permission of Children of the Code.
- My teacher asked me to come
into the front of the class
and read a book
and everybody was just staring at me
and I got real nervous
'cause I didn't want
to mess up or anything.
And then when I started reading,
I started messing up
and I just couldn't help it
and everybody started
laughing at me and stuff.
- Like the teacher would
ask me to read something
and I would read it and
I'd get a wrong word
or I'd go too slow and
they'll make fun of me.
- I kept messing up on the words
and people kept laughing at me.
- They said that you
don't know how to read,
I bet you won't be able to
how to read when you grow up.
- They always laugh at me if
I get twist up with words.
It makes my heart drop
'cause it seem like they
not my friend no more.
- The collateral damage
caused by literacy problems
in the United States alone is immense.
75% to 80% of students
identified as learning disabled
have their basic deficits
in language and reading.
Academic success,
as defined by high school graduation,
can be predicted by knowing
someone's reading skill
at the end of third grade.
56% of students with learning disabilities
will drop out of school and be arrested.
60% of adolescents in
treatment for substance abuse
have learning disabilities.
50% of females with learning
disabilities will be mothers,
many of them single mothers,
within three to five years
of leaving high school.
Learning disabilities and substance abuse
are the number one reason for
keeping welfare recipients
from becoming and remaining employed.
Now I'm gonna turn to discussing
how modern technologies
are impacting reading
and writing today.
Lest we forget,
the human brain is an
exquisitely adaptable machine.
Even though written language
did not evolve like spoken language did
over tens of millions of years ago,
since the invention of
writing and reading,
the remarkable neuroplasticity
of the human brain
has supported the rapid formation
of a highly elaborate
literacy brain circuit.
Literacy is a unique
epigenetic achievement
that changes what we perceive,
how we think and how we feel,
that is who we are.
I think it's fair to say
that reading and writing,
perhaps more than any other technology
have had the greatest impact
on the advancement of Homo
sapien brain and mind.
As we gain proficiency
in reading and writing,
the continual use of our
literacy brain circuit
feeds back, elaborates
and strengthens itself.
But just as this brain
circuit developed very rapidly
in evolutionary terms
or perhaps because it was so rapid,
this circuit is also more
vulnerable to change,
if not continuously reinforced
by experience and use.
Only if we continuously work
to develop and use the
elaborated, analytical,
inferential and empathetic skills
that have been developed by literacy
will the neural networks
underlying these skills
continue to sustain our
capacity to be attentive,
thoughtful, critical thinkers
rather than passive consumers
of facts, real or fake.
Despite alphabetic writing
not changing much since the invention
of the printing press in the 15th century,
modern technologies, particularly
social media technologies
are having a very rapid
and profound effect
on writing practices in the 21st century.
Interestingly, many of
these new technologies
are making less use of
alphabetic writing systems
and more use once again of pictographs,
as can be seen here
comparing the Egyptian
hieroglyphics of 3100 BC
to a thank you note I recently
received from my niece
that says, "Dinner was awesome.
"It was a gift.
"Thanks."
And another example,
a Chinese pictograph for medical marijuana
originally from 10,000 years ago
and a clip art symbol for
medical marijuana from 2017.
Since the 15th century,
despite many changes in spoken English
from old English to middle English
to early modern and late modern English,
like here it says, then
she went to speak the
whatever English tongue,
written English has
used the same 26 letters
to represent the 44 sounds
of English until now.
The bottom line reads,
"Then she went to speak this
digital age English tongue."
Neuroscientists like me
who specialize in reading
are frequently asked these days
how might these rapid
technological changes
in reading and writing
affect the human mind?
My colleague, Dr. Maryanne Wolf,
focuses on exactly this question
in her new book Reader, Come Home.
I'd like to close with some
of the profound insights
from this timely book.
"As we move from a literary
and word-based culture
"into a far faster paced
digital and screen-based one,
"we face an existential
dilemma in this new millennium.
"There are many things that would be lost
"if we slowly lose the cognitive patience
"to immerse ourselves in the worlds
"that are created by books
"and the lives, feelings,
thoughts and insights
"of the characters who inhabit them."
In a culture that increasingly rewards
immediacy, ease and efficiency,
the demanding time and effort involved
in what Dr. Wolfe refers
to as, deep reading
make it an increasingly embattled entity.
In closing, I ask each of you
to consider this question,
will the very plasticity
of the literate brain
as it begins to reflect the
characteristics of digital media
that we and our children are increasingly
immersing ourselves in
precipitate the atrophy
of our most essential thought processes,
sustained attention, critical analysis,
empathy and reflection
and indeed wisdom,
to the detriment of democratic societies
that critically depend on these,
the most essential characteristics
of the enlightened, literate individual?
Thank you.
(audience applause)
(upbeat music)